he's one of our favorite guests he's
been on here i think he even
chris did he did he um did he guest host
this program
once upon a time uh i don't think so i
think he cut like a kind of a fun like
promo back in the day oh for for for it
was
it was ballin he was he was polite yes
here on this show which he does talk
about which he does professionally
uh television movies unicorn on cbs
right now thursdays at 9 30 pm
on cbs and now top gear america uh which
premieres today exclusively on the motor
trend app
rob cordrey on this program how are you
rob oh man
it is good to hear your voice right back
at you you know i
i i'm i'm wondering what let's let's
just jump right into let's just jump
right into what you're here to promote
and then we can talk about it then we
could talk about us
um so uh the motor trend app this is how
i can buy
gamestop stock right is that how i is
that what this app is for or is it a
different app oh
oh no you you've been you've been you
should
fire your broker oh gosh so this has
nothing to do with that
you've been given really bad information
okay so what what is that then let me
let me give you the floor then
what what do we got here with the uh
motor trend app and then top gear
america that you and shepard look at
that and uh and jethro
bulvington walk me through all this
yeah man it's um boy it's uh
it's it was one of the
one of maybe a very small handful of
things that
i was offered and
and and immediately knew that i was
going to do
okay you know i've been you know car
guy for ever and
and this is the gig right and
and i essentially i i kind of
understood right away what why they were
calling me because
i'm not the kind of guy that that can
talk for a half an hour about
limited slip differentials but
but i i'm an enthusiast and i've made it
known
and and i think so i was like oh i
this this is very smart of them actually
i'm gonna represent represent the viewer
like i'll be
the viewer transported onto the screen
slash app um
and uh and man the three of us have had
a great time
wouldn't even know where to begin i
gotta tell you rob i mean it's similar
to
the way i view my gig with nfl network
you know where i guess the
sports cars or the dream cars are
actually like uh hall of fame athletes
that i get to hang out with and i
i put the fans in my shoes like you know
i mean it's not like i know the
x's and o's and the cover three defenses
and the stunts and all that stuff like
the back of my hand but i do love the
sport and i do love
you know the athletes and i just want to
put the fans in my shoes so that sounds
like the role that you're playing here
on this show it's it's yeah
right on the nose um yeah and
and you know from the first time you
came on you people could tell that
because you know you're
you were just uh you you know guys
always say like they'll be joking around
watching a game
they'll be like they should put us on tv
we could do better than these guys you
are like
you are like the guy transported
from that group of friends thank god you
got rid of them
[Laughter]
what's your first car what was the first
car you ever got
rob oh well get ready ladies um
a 1975 ford pinto wagon
oh my god were those weren't those the
ones that if you got rear-ended they
exploded
wasn't that one of those that was no
that was that was the uh
coupe that was the coupe okay this was
the wagon
really upscale
[Music]
and it had had no floorboards like the
flintstones
you used your feet is that what you're
saying flintstones car
we every time and it wasn't on my side
it was it was on the passenger side so
every time
i went over a puddle which in boston was
frequently
my girlfriend would get wet
no kidding so that's your first car
um not likely to appear on any episodes
i imagine of top year america that
vehicle
ever it's not the most exciting car but
um
i don't know that's what i kind of love
about top gear is that
because i love every kind of car i love
that
car because i remember the smell of it
you know
and there's something to love about
about
almost every car um
and and and we are sometimes challenged
to
you know do the we squeeze the most we
can out of these
uh uh mistakes
yes so was there uh an eight-track
um ability in this vehicle
no no i think that if i remember
correctly there was
like an aftermarket radio in there with
a uh
with it with a cassette player so
i was um that was like i was
right on i mean it was no no it was
definitely it was definitely an
aftermarket radio
um because i uh i remember throwing the
beastie boys license to hill out the
window of my car
after i had played it too much
uh to understand anymore so somebody's
like uh
impala ran it over or something like
that is that what you're saying once it
throughout the window or
hey man you know you it's you direct it
in your head
and i'll direct it in mine rob cordrey
here on the rich eisen show again uh
motor trends top gear
america with uh he dak shepard and
jethro buffington
can be uh watched and enjoyed starting
today on all media players and streaming
devices
where you can watch a show like uh top
gear america
um so your uh patriot fandom
uh how does that uh compute with what's
going on with the current quarterback of
the tampa bay buccaneers
rob are you happy for him are you hate
watching this
what are you doing right now watching
tb12 oh yeah
yeah i'm i'm you know it's almost i
almost feel like i have
two teams okay right now
because the the combination of brady and
gronk
was almost silly
uh and uh
and i really enjoyed watching the
patriots
you know try and get it together and uh
and you know cam
one of the best quarterbacks of uh the
last decade
or so and and so i don't know it's been
i think it's made what has would
otherwise have been
a just kind of odd season pretty
watchable
so you are rooting for tom to win his
seventh is what you're saying
i think this kid's gonna go all the way
i think so too but then there's mahomes
as well where are you gonna watch the
super bowl you planning on watching it
or
where are you gonna watch it patrick
mahomes isn't
bad at football he's correct yeah by the
way if this is the keen
analysis you're bringing to cars at top
gear america then this is going to be
phenomenal
this is going to be why i lose fantasy
football man this is the
this is why i don't have your job oh my
gosh where are you gonna watch the super
bowl you plan on it or you got
what um well yeah well we don't know we
don't have a plan actually but
i assume we have like a little
pod family of friends that okay
we hang out with and um
i assume it'll probably be over here
with them or
over there well because nobody in my
family cares
well that's you got to make him care rob
you got to sit him down you got to make
him care
you know i tried to tell you how to
parents i must have told you this over
the years
like how i've tried to convince my
daughter that
football was worth watching because you
know the running backs sometimes they
take ballet classes
yes that's true look at look at right
there look at that
look at that wait where you going didn't
work didn't work
like not but no not buying it at all not
yet
no no hey look if you if you ever
you know uh need any assistance on
getting any uh
any children um i'm constantly to to
watch football i'm constantly
you know trading off stuff too like arm
twisting just watching movies
too or just twisting arms to make sure
that they the other day actually
you know uh my kids watched the war with
grandpa
uh rob and i realized in the middle of
it it's their first robert de niro movie
and what do i do with that sort of thing
oh no
you know well listen don't worry about
it you messed up but you
you weren't you just now you know you
know now
to think before you act right well which
which one of your movies would you want
people to watch first so they can get
the full rob cordray sense
of things that they understand yes right
you know i imagine de niro wouldn't
choose that one
but i imagine at this point in his
career he's like i don't care what
whatever you want
but i guess in good parenting as i
didn't throw a deer hunter in first
you know what i mean like um well yeah
yeah you see what i'm saying yeah i i um
uh what was the question
[Music]
which one of your movies would you want
someone to watch first so they could
totally yeah well
machine i think okay that's that one
i guess sure it's the easiest answer hey
uh
did you see last one for you uh did you
did you see jon stewart joined twitter
yesterday
did you see that i i i just saw that
five minutes before i called you how
about that did you ever think you'd see
that day
rob how about that one well first of all
i didn't know he wasn't on twitter
um but so
okay you know right um but
i uh but then i was like well of course
when i read that i said of course he was
not on twitter and
this was uh this was the story that got
him out i love it
um and i'm gonna i'm gonna
direct message him that the second we
hang up
to say uh welcome to twitter you're
gonna hate it
i think you by the way that is a very
and and it is also within 240 characters
you could also tweet that out publicly
uh i could say it twice you could that's
the thing of twitter
like i said who's gonna do it you're
right look i'm just trying to workshop
it for you rob
credit i'll give you credit that's all
good at rich eisen all right so
uh thank you for joining uh here on the
show top gear america
premieres today exclusively on the motor
trend app um
hang out with rob and dax and uh and
jethro uh anytime you want in the
unicorn on cbs
airing thursdays at 9 30 pm eastern on
the tiffany network
thanks again for the call rob you take
care um it's been great talking to you
man
right back at you brother it's been far
too long it has come
let's keep in touch and that's not one
of those things to say to somebody
publicly i actually would direct message
that to you no no no
no because it's it's felt it's heartfelt
it is right here
thanks for the call i truly mean it you
take care bud
all right that's rob cordray everybody
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here